nos piden dividir 1.0 30 y 75 en 3.25 lo
primero que hay que hacer cuando tienen
decimales en el número que divide es
multiplicarlo por 10 las veces
suficientes para que se vuelva un número
entero al multiplicar algo por 10 el
punto decimal se desplaza a un lugar a
la derecha en este caso queremos
desplazar una dos veces vamos a
multiplicar punto 25 por 100 y el punto
se va a desplazar una dos veces nos
quedará 25 pero si hacemos esto con el
divisor también tenemos que hacerlo con
el dividendo lo de adentro de esta
casita y pues entonces vamos a desplazar
el punto decimal dos lugares a la
derecha también
2 aquí queda el punto y aquí en el
resultado el punto va a quedar acá y
para que vean porque esto tiene sentido
tenemos que darnos cuenta que todo esto
lo podemos reescribir como 1.030 75
entre 0.25
si esto de aquí abajo lo multiplicamos
por 100
y esto de aquí arriba también lo
multiplicamos por 100 que es lo que
estamos haciendo aquí para desplazar el
punto decimal dos lugares a la derecha
esto es cómo multiplicar todo esto por 1
100 entre 100 voy a reescribir esto para
que se vea más claro aunque ustedes no
tienen que hacerlo al multiplicar por
100 dividendo y divisor nos queda 25 que
divide a
103 punto 0 75 y el punto lo pondremos
aquí arriba ok es un arte encontrar el
número para comenzar a hacer la
operación entonces veamos 25 no entra en
uno tendremos que tomar estos dos
números 25 no entra en 10 pues no vamos
a tener que tomar 3 números 25 si entra
en 103 ahora si podemos utilizar bueno
vamos a probar a multiplicar por cuatro
4 x 25 4 por 5 es 20 llevamos 24 por 28
2 que llevamos son 10
103 - 100 nos va a quedar 3
ahora vamos a tomar este 0 y lo vamos a
bajar aquí
tenemos 30 que número x 25 se acerca 30
pues va a ser 125 por 1 es 25 hacemos
esta resta y nos queda 5
ahora vamos a tomar este 7 y lo vamos a
bajar
de manera que nos queda 57 que número x
25 se acerca a 57 pues va a ser 225 por
12 50 50 lo escribo aquí 57 menos 50 es
igual a 7 ahora que me queda pues me
queda bajar este 5 acá medio sueco pero
aquí va tengo 75 que número x 25 se
acerca 75 vamos a probar con 33 por 5 15
llevó 13 por 26 más una que llevo son 7
75 75 resulta una división exacta no
tengo residuo así que 25 cabe
exactamente 4.123 veces en 103 puntos 0
75 aquí escribo es exactamente el mismo
resultado 4.1
1 2 3 y es exactamente lo mismo que esta
operación 4.123
y hoy aquí terminamos con este vídeo